hello and welcome to PlayStation great
it's time to wrap up yet another season
of fortnight Battle Royale season 8 it's
in the history books and was full of
memes Easter eggs and old cultural
references I can't get enough of so
let's break them down oh let's try
something a little bit new we already
know what's happening in season 9 so
what will happen at the start of season
10 I love it when people speculate so
have a crack at it whoever gets closest
I will sort out a reward good luck
anyway let's do this season 8 began on
February 28th and ended on May 8 2019
the battle pass was given away for free
this time some say it was out of the
goodness of Epic's heart others say it
was because of apex legends what do you
think anyway giving away a free battle
pass means
default skins were a thing of the past
rip the dream the seasons theme was x
marks the spot a pirate theme with a
cool new mechanic treasure maps leading
to gold chests such a great addition
season 8 also brought us the ballers I'm
sure you've heard them called many
things maybe the hamster balls or monkey
balls the original inspiration is from a
game released in 2001 called Super
Monkey Ball it's one of the weirdest and
most wonderful Japanese games if you
haven't played it you should it's pretty
damn awesome you'll instantly recognize
the bouncing sound effect the Fortnight
design also takes into account the
gyrosphere from jurassic world to offer
comfortable seating arrangements by the
way did you ever ride past the dinosaurs
while singing the Jurassic Park they've
Jude
[Music]
many people also see huge similarities
to the overwatch character Hammond who
is literally a hamster in a wrecking
ball this does follow a trend a
fortnight borrowing characters from that
universe Oh segue last season I
completely forgot to add this character
as an easter egg she's literally on the
thumbnail and I didn't say anything
about her swatting it now this is Ark
who's obviously based on mercy right I
can't wait to get my hands on at the
fortnight version of tracer I can't wait
for that to be stolen I mean we have
reimagined
to do this oh this is a good point to
include other Easter eggs that I've
missed in the past this emote is in
reference to Will Smith yeah yeah that
guy went on the red carpet he tried not
to take centerstage away from his wife
and did this instead
a youtuber named JT showed me this next
one the paper aeroplane glider has a
schoolboy scribbling inside one of which
is my name's Jeff I'm sure you know that
meme yeah there's another returning meme
in season eight thanks to this quarry
design which looks like a fork and knife
if you remember we had a mobile kitchen
moving around the island which prevented
that meme from dying fYI the fork knife
meme was created over on Twitter when a
young lady tried to impress her man with
her fortnight skills hilarity ensued the
map updates are a freaking volcano
appear and wipeout wailing woods and
risky reels item Utley was gutted to
seize risky reels gone forever the block
somehow survived which was moved to the
other side of the map and replaced the
motel instead another one of my favorite
areas FAMU fortnight the volcano itself
is designed with Lord of the Rings in
might spoiler alert the ending scene in
the Lord of the Rings trilogy in which
Gollum and Frodo go head-to-head for the
ring master hobbits off my gone
impression sounds more like Elmo's blah
blah blah get a life that scene ended
with Gollum dying in the lava and the
ring becoming one with earth again and
then Gollum gave the thumbs up to John
Connor hang on I may be getting my movie
references mixed up just before we crack
on a quick thanks to those who've used
my code a damaru in the fort night shop
I dub thee the renegades you guys make
this video possible thank you so much
send me a picture on Twitter if you'd
like to join these renegade legends next
time I'm Adam grenade over there thanks
again for your support I love you 3,000
so the pirate code popped up which has a
subtle nod to the movie castaway just
north of the ship is a very tiny island
on which someone is trying to call for
help with the good old SOS symbol I'm
not sure why because the water is not
deep at all well in castaway Tom Hanks
is all alone so to keep him company on
the island he uses a football named
Wilson and that round bugger is here too
just just don't kick him in the water
other new areas or buildings upgraded to
pirates nests with gold to be harvest
and those ballers have we already talked
about the ballers do you remember the og
bunkering wailing woods what it has
survived it's been pushed over to the
right of the volcano I'm not sure why
that is important but I have a feeling
it is originally it was an easter egg to
the TV series lost but this thing has
taken a life of its own any predictions
throw them in the comments below what
the heck are these bunkers for in the
battle pass we had many goodies to
unlock the banana skin was the season's
WTF moment but when paired with the
unlockable emotes the reference becomes
obvious 12 years ago we would say it's
peanut butter jelly time it's so widely
known that even Family Guy got in on the
act
y:i jelly to those outside the US is Jam
saying peanut butter jelly in the UK is
a little bit more gross than you'd
expect this chap became unlockable in
the season 8 battle bus homage to Naruto
or Naruto as I'm told to say it his
tiger mask is in the anime too the
fortnight Naruto is constantly chasing
down keys in the load screen which is
another reference to jahmai village
sorry if I've said that completely wrong
in the land of the keys no less sunny
steps is Naruto's home I was reading
about the keys in Aztec stories which
all suggest portals in time boom that's
it time-travel confirmed for season 9
hit the alley a music
sorry damn I need to stop doing that
the final unblockable is none other than
lifeline from apex legends she's
obviously not but just look at her she
really is she's almost identical AJ she
would be proud just an untruth the axiom
outfit hit the shops which is based on
Cyclops and his old G blue and yellow
suit from the Marvel comic books in a
genius change the single I became three
so Cyclops became Triclops those goggles
are likely most well known thanks to Sam
Fisher in the Splinter Cell series the
dream feat emote became available in
season 8 which is taken from the legend
that is John Jacobson and his sick moves
this one is double dream feet come on
what a legend I'll link his video below
it's so terrible it's great another
dance named scenario is from the Korean
boyband icon and their song loved
scenario so vanoss and the Marvel team
returned for yet another LTM but the
kicker was those real and dark skins in
the item shop Black Widow and star-lord
which is ironic I suppose as the rust
Lord is a homage to Peter quill if you
didn't see their accompanying emotes
they are taking directly from the movies
black widows evade pose is from many
other fight scenes
whereas star-lords dance is almost a
perfect recreation of the dance-off in
guardians of the galaxy before we look
at the main event of the season here's a
quick look inside the vault which it
looks inspired by destiny - under trials
of the nine even that bubble thing in
the distance is very reminiscent of
destiny - also the desk it indicates an
architect for the world just like in the
matrix so maybe we are neo and we'll get
another Keanu Reeves skin in the coming
season
before we relive the unbolting event
let's take a look at a few hidden map
updates and stories we saw this time
around firstly snobby shores began to be
overrun by Vikings creating what could
be the new Viking village in season nine
sunny steps like I've already said
brought in those Aztec influences but
the real story of season 8 was the love
story between these two beasts the rock
man and the rock girl from wailing woods
somehow survived their destruction
rebuilt themselves before trying to find
one another they slowly walked closer
over the 10 weeks the rock the Dwayne
Johnson picked up a flower for his
sweetheart while she acted alcool stood
by a tree women I'll never understand
them in the final weeks they were parted
by lava certain death or was it Sharon
loves her man and leaps into the lava
like a complete badass
whereas rock Dwayne Johnson isn't as
manly as you'd think slowly lowering
himself down thankfully though they
found each other and sat ready for the
new season
what a great side story legitimately my
favorite in fortnight history I hope it
continues next season the food fight
which has raged on for seemingly years
finished in season 8 a quick recap after
pizza pit was replaced with a
time-traveling pyramid
yeah that sounds weird to say and the
derp burger went out of business the two
set up mobile kitchens and battled for
custom everywhere
finally they both set up in retail row
and grew enormous empires long story
short the volcano destroyed them will
they return or is this the end of the
food fight I personally hope it's over
I'd rather watch some stone monsters
getting jiggy with it
so now for the overarching storyline of
fought night over until tipped our 's
that one building that always gets
destroyed was destroyed it's again but
this time an insurance company popped up
surely they know how to put together a
strong building right over the first few
weeks of the season the men in black or
maybe the government began digging
around the island it first looked as
though they were relieving the pressure
on the island unleashing geysers but in
fact they were looking for
something eventually under loot Lake
they found it it was discovered a bloody
vault I mean of all it's not a bloody
for spin British is hard all right I
gotta admit it looks just like an alien
ship from Independence Day but I guess
I'm wrong
Oh as a side thought is the u.s.
independence day in next season's
timeline I wonder if it'll play a part
in the story as we all know the u.s.
claimed independence from aliens
thanks to Will Smith what a guy back to
the story after weeks of theories and
guesses the moment came for the event to
begin well ok nothing happened for me
but for a few people it was a real event
and this is what happened
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so that's where we're at at the end of
season 8 can you believe that one single
building survived the volcano blast GG
Epic Games great trolling dirt that was
pretty impressive what the hell will
happen next I'd love to know your
thoughts I can't figure it out if I've
missed any Easter eggs or references
please let me know on our name drop you
in the next video I'm Adam from
Playstation grenade please think about
using coded oamaru and I'll see you next
time
all the best
[Music]
[Applause]